alors 340 mille euros de prime est ce
que vous êtes choqués ou non je vous
pose la question tout le monde en a
parlé aujourd'hui
non non non oui oui oui à géraldine
manier y avoir maintenant c'est plus le
tennis et le foot
tiens j'ai 'roadshow' que tient
aujourd'hui à plus grand chose qui me
choque donc ce serait peut-être pas la
manquer non je suis choquée parce que je
m'attendais pas un oui parents comme
comme amateurs de foot et je pensais
qu'on allait peut-être plus se
confronter mes amis oui je vais
mais bon moi je suis je suis choquée
donc quand on voit aujourd'hui les
circonstances actuelles de ce que la
majorité des français vivent du nombre
de personnes qui vont entrer sur le
marché de la misère d'ici septembre
parce que fo s'apercevoir qu'aujourd'hui
les gens sont en train de chuter ils
n'ont toujours pas atterri
l'atterrissage va être douloureux et on
distribue aujourd'hui des milliers
d'euros donc j'ai fait le calcul ça fait
à peu près 8 millions d'euros sur 22 8
millions d'euros sur 22 joueurs parce
que tout le monde même si un mec qui n'a
pas touché le ballon de tout truc qui
prend les 300 cas là comme vous quand
vous êtes ici quand vous paie dit pas un
mot vous prenez quand même pas de cacher
8 millions d'euros ça prouve au moins
que cet argent et péter crêpes a été
utile aujourd'hui ton locaux vides est
ce qu'il aurait été pas été utile
la situation me tiens juste à rappeler
aujourd'hui on attaque on annonce 340
mille euros de prime par joueur l'action
gagne aujourd'hui 1er juin vous avez
trente mille familles qui vont être
expulsés mais c'est ce que vivent la
majorité des français aujourd'hui
j'entends saleri dit jérôme
en revanche cet argent c'est un peu
démago de dire ça effectivement c'est
facile de dire je suis choquée parce que
oui la somme est astronomique et ni dans
toute une vie on peut plus faire voilà
on gagne pas ça mais cet argent de toute
façon ni revenir sur français précaire
c'est ça cet argent n'irait de cet
argent à ce moment là pourquoi donner
cet argent à ce moment-là ça alors ça
c'est une entreprise privée face à l'as
et rapporte encore plus
j'imagine que ce qu'ils vont prendre ce
qu'ils abattent ça va donner vous
parliez effectivement d'une situation en
ce moment alors super nes connaît de
l'album il ya une notoriété derrière
c'est à dire que si on ne donne cet
argent ainsi qu'ils l'ont mérité d'avoir
ces accords mais sur quels principes à
20 jours au foot
bah oui est ce qu'aujourd'hui elles se
passent confére dorer le blason de la
france nerfs d'accord est ce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'ya pas des milliers
de français qui sont capables d'être
aussi performant pour faire redorer le
blason de la france et qu'ils vont
toucher 500 d'argent voir ici oui mais
je n'en vois pas ici une prime de
performance et pour associer les joueurs
à la victoire de la france qui
rapporterait 34 c'est pareil dans tous
les pays il faut le dire voilà je l'aimé
il ya une prime de prévu si le pays
gagne alors un pari pour le rôle mondial
a donc nous on a dit la fédération a dit
c'est bien d'associer les joueurs quand
ils ont gagné la coupe du monde chacun a
gagné quatre cent mille euros de primes
et bien
cui bono reversés à des associations le
dire forcément les plus grands les plus
grands série l'on connaît bien certains
comme par exemple quand on a parlé qui
est toujours reverser l'argent a bondi à
d'autres mais aujourd'hui au vu de ce
qui se passe en france au vu de la
misère qui s'annonce
on peut comprendre que la majorité des
français puissent être choqués insiste
le mans par cette somme parce que comme
je le répète il ya des milliers de gens
par exemple qui se sont battus pour
sauver des vies est ce qu'ils vont
toucher e314 ou est ce qu'une vie ce
souci c'est qu'ils m'appellent en direct
on va voir ce qu'il en pense
ouais mon frérot ça va ça va frère c'est
sur l'émission là qu'est ce que tu dis
toi sur la prime tu voulais tu puisses
qui traînait là dessus mais les primes
et en maîtrisant mal ses 10 points
d'accord donc il y avait maria lema ti
pays l'équipe de france voilà pour être
une vitrine
d'accord ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
l'équipe de france est championne du
monde aujourd'hui donc c'est une vitrine
puis c'est ça c'est l'esprit du surf upa
et bien sûr pompiers bah oui oui mais ça
reste de l'argent
non mais c'est ça l'explication de
djibril à des balades ateliers et
reverse aux joueurs bah voilà les
joueurs ce qui est vrai c'est que la
plupart de nos aïeux reverse à des
affiches à exactement les créations qui
enrôle et djibrine merci tu es payé pour
cette intervention
j'aurais même si tu fais toujours ta
collection de vêtements j'ai toujours
rien reçu
merci c'est vrai qu'en écoutant le
numéro d'une personne qui travaille dans
l'audiovisuel il faut l'appeler c'est
vrai moi djibril je t'aime frère et tu
viendrais je vois la page tu veux qu'on
arrange bien regarder des matches à la
maison c'est bien mais je t'aime je
t'aime a changé merci mon frère on voit
la voiture il portait un infirmier ne
représentera pas nike ou une autre
marque n'aura pas le droit de toucher
lui il m'énerve une énorme prime parce
que si on se rappelle du ségur c'est
peanuts parce que si vous prenez la
plupart des soignants ne vont rien
toucher et ne vont rien gagné enfin je
sais pas un moment donné il ya des
périodes serait pas choqué peut-être en
90 et est moins choquant peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui c'est peut-être un peu
plus choquant au but
parce que l'ensemble des français
aujourd'hui vivent alors je sais pas il
ya un gap qui a une frontière faut juste
s'apercevoir de ce à quoi s'est bien
repris avec nicolas perdrix saint-jérôme
j'entends ce que vous dites mais ses
erreurs du passé normalement mais c'est
une erreur
c'est une vraie erreur de communication
facile toujours comme ça et suspend la
prime je vous dire pourquoi mais est-ce
que c'est qu'il ya erreur nous a dit que
je voulais arrêter comme le revers ils
reversent tous
ils n'ont pas besoin de cet argent il
reverse tous cet argent à des
associations
c'est plutôt noble alias java shedleur
pas où c'est un peu con de d'avoir
continué à parler de cette semaine aux
cimes de performance est alors allée
maillot nantais c'est la tradition après
ils remercient s'il gagne pas il n'y a
pas de performance donc ils n'ont pas
cet avis et puissant a pas besoin de ça
ils la reverse tout ça fait vraiment ch
je donne actuellement vous savez pas
tous parce que moi je suis choquée pour
les 340 milles mais j'ai pas le même
discours que gironde parce que c'est une
société privée c'est pas là c'est pas
l'argent du contribuable c'est des
sponsors et cetera et cetera
mais il faut savoir que d'abord on sait
pas si tous reverse moi je pense pas
qu'ils reversent tout cet argent ils
font ce qu'ils veulent avec la avec sa
revanche mais juste sur etes-vous choqué
oui je suis choquée 340 mille euros pour
aller jouer pour l'équipe de france
ça m'aurait pas dérangé qu'ils y aillent
pour trente ou quarante mille euros du
lanceur de jeu déjà une grosse somme
mais des coups des meneuses ou ceux qui
vont là on s'en fout des javelots ceux
qui vont là c'est l'élite et prennent
déjà 300 400 mille euros minimum par
maury mais ils n'ont pas besoin de
beaucoup plus vous savez pas si vous
leur donnez moi sur le choquer pour moi
ça fait de baraques pour moi tout ça à
tous combien de tournois sur deux sera
certes beaucoup moins parce qu a pas de
modèle économique autour de ce sport là
le foot à un système très lucratif donc
si des joueurs général et des sponsors
mois est alors arrivé un truc important
moi personnellement parce que je le dis
ne serait ce qu'avec les gens avec qui
je manifeste
je m'insurge pas contre la personne qui
touchent l'argent parce que moi je veux
dire honnêtement je suis un être humain
le mec il wendel 200 millions je les
prends battu venir alors je ne sais pas
si j'en passe est ce que ces grandes
sociétés qui sont capables de financer
la recrue pourrait plutôt répété
l'offrir directement pour que les cds
mieux cité et c'est de l'argent qui
payent pour qu'on leur fasse de la pub
et donc pour générer de l'argent c'est
la connais quand ça d'ici avril slaoui
de france est championne du sponsor qui
paye in running en fait voilà voilà
alors elle s'est précipitée sur l'irak
est mal et qu'il connaît très bien le
foot bien mieux que le tennis c'est
effectivement cdma pour le maillot aux
bois pour la marque
oui mais monsieur parmi les plus
précaires moi je suis d'accord avec ce
que vous dites mais là vous faites de
l'idée
j mais est-ce que par pragmatisme
effectivement comme l'année a été très
dure avec le co vide
il devrait leur verser ils devraient le
donner au foot amateur je connais la
situation mais voilà mais je pense que
malgré tout tous leur reverse à des
associés à bien plus enviable un grave
on a bondi aux états unis parmi les plus
précaires il y en a beaucoup et tous
peut-être regarde l'équipe de france
rennes de l'équipe de france
regardant la télévision rêve d'avoir
même un maillot de bain et des rates
heures il n'y a aucun doute là dessus je
leur suis pas très foot non plus je je
participe aux grands événements comme la
coupe d'europe
j'ai deux nations aux formats moi le
premier je suis passionné par ce genre
de choses un peu moins suis pas très
foot canapé au final mais un moment
donné faut juste voilà se rendre compte
que aujourd'hui dans le climat actuel ça
puisse choquer des personnes bien les
énormes sommes comme ça quand des gens
ont passé leur temps à sauver des vies
quoi d'accord bien ça l'isabelle qu'on
apporte aux jeunes on est tous d'accord
0 mais on est tous d'accord aussi moi je
suis d'accord pour l'assainissement du
milieu du football je trouve que les
sommes qui sont vraiment parler
commencera pardon olesz a en revanche
puisque là-bas maintenant le système il
est ce qu'il est pour l'instant
et ils l'ont ils l'ont pas volée et
c'est moins que la con du monde
précédentes a effectivement les rovers
évidemment droite où on n'est pas des
ennuis tanguay robert après sarah
prouvez moi j'ai pas d'une règle non
plus vraiment à leur dédiant d'ailleurs
il ya plusieurs matches ils doivent
avoir gagné plusieurs matches dans ces
cas des one man
oui j'ai vu d'un bon oeil avait
pareillement 2010 non spécialisés
football il n'a pas réclamé cette fois
ça c'est intéressant souvent ils
venaient négocier des radiations et là
la fédé d'emblée a dit c'est ça 'cela
fait bcp salariale et clame voilà tout
le monde a fermé sa tronche est
absolument
et ça a été attribuée comme ça oui kelly
bas après ce qui aurait pu être un petit
peu plus de décence et la discrète la
discrétion de ce montant et on n'est pas
tout seul
tous savent l'arrivée aussi j'ai les
médias est ce que je comprends que les
gens et les boules aussi donc c'est vrai
que ça peut être plus discutés les gens
ils ont les boules parce que ces
quarante cinq piges de crédit en trois
semaines
[Musique]
ces cours vous bien gentil choque pas je
vais poser la question ils n'ont pas
volé la question au chauffeur de 20 ans
et il m'a dit la même chose à un moment
donné sur le service de la nation
est ce que ces 8 millions de route on
était peut-être mais ça c'est quand est
ce que tu sens du concret aujourd'hui
c'est des chansons du concret l'équipe
de france qui va sauver la mère de la
france on est en ce moment avec les
milliards alors doit rembourser sarah
narnia il ya des filières qui traîne de
l'autre côté donc de faire venir un truc
que je viens de recevoir son aide à
mieux d'une amie marie france chatrier
ah oui ou non pourra jamais oui j'adore
marie françois lamy c'est une amie
proche chéri d'amour pour une fois pas
d'accord avec vous il me dire moi un
anneau dans le tennis et la sphère des
joueurs elle revient sûr il ya déclaré
raison a très bien ils en sont
responsables auprès du public qui fait
vivre toute une économie sera de voir la
presse on est le relais ce sport est
déjà thomas ici bien sûr profusion des
initiatives sur le circuit va conduire
au n'importe quoi avant marif les nerfs
des joueurs qui ne sont plus capables
d'assurer la pression pour transformer
le tennis en une jungle où seul l'argent
aura la loi le sport se joue de toutes
les discriminations dormi et une voix
celle des sangs mêlés contre le racisme
celle des femmes car elle est la
sportive la plus payé de toute
l'histoire du sport elle a des devoirs
et ses petites déprimes de championne
d'arles sont insupportables à la main
sur rihanna je suis son ami
mais l'argent la gagne crée aussi des
devoirs vous embrassons cyril mais pas
d'accord bon je sais que mon avis n'a
aucune importance sur le tennis mais je
ne suis pas une chèvre comme géraldine
mail
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime beaucoup à des fourneaux mais
osaka qui la verra la sphère en
conférence de presse
elle ajouté michele est essentielle tous
les chiens est-ce que celui à 37,63 a
choqué les gens envoyer les gens à la
maison plutôt pas choquer bonjour j'ai
envie mais on est plus précaire qui les
soutiennent le plus souvent parce que ça
les fait rêver
alors oui je suis pas je suis pas contre
sa démission de rêve il en existe plein
aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est pas ça le
souci au final moi je ne suis pas contre
les gens qui gagnent de l'argent et je
voudrais aussi où on enlève cette image
s'il le mérite de le gagner et il mérite
de le gagner est attendu aujourd'hui
donc dans les circonstances actuelles il
faut comprendre qu'il ya des gens qui
vont tomber dans la misère on en reparle
peut-être en scène bien deux sociétés
vont couler concept juillet il ya des
chômeurs ils vont toucher 300 est ce que
les gens voient là moi je suis d'accord
pour le rêve j'ai travaillé à disney et
vendent du rêve c'est ce que je faisais
de mieux à un moment donné mais voilà
aujourd'hui la réalité est l'excellent
esprit c'est le terrain qui paraît autre
mère du football jérôme da